all right all right so the lawyers here  are telling me that I have to say this I  don't really want to but I will last  week I did a monologue on the Southern  Poverty Law Center they took issue yes  issue with me with some of the  statements made on the show including a  joke a joke that they do virtually no  law but in fact they say they spent over  1.8 million in 2015 on out-of-pocket  case costs for litigation on behalf of  their clients so we must make clear now  that SPLC  does in fact quote do law unquote SPLC  also uses offshore investment vehicles  which it says is common for nonprofit  organizations to do that's great in my  opinion they hurt decent people like  Rand Paul Hirsi Ali  Maajid Nawaz and ben Carson for whom  they actually apologized by labeling  them as extremists and to me that still  sucks